[Music]
so who uses tick-tock
I do you do you're such a responsible
social media person what do you do like
what are your tick tocks I do some music
stuff and then I also do like just some
some comedy sketches you dance and
dancing no no no I do like oh no you
guys know the song ain't no fun at the
only course so I did one were like I was
a teacher because I felt like corrupt
always the corrupt verse sounds like
he's teaching the course this is I they
have a grub gave a [ __ ] about a [ __ ]
I'd always be broke
I never had no [ __ ] I guess
locked in mony [ __ ] you can't do this
so I did it like that so I decided I'm
instrumental playing underneath they
kind of like sound like it so I get away
with it but why didn't you do the thing
where what is that thing they move they
the way they move their [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they move the camera at the same time so
it creates a little musically thing yeah
what well that's what they do and take
our - I don't know how did that just I'm
not that well don't know your media my
friend I don't do you do you to talk
what second of your decision of like yes
or no they call me the money man on
there okay why not the Ice Man your
branding is all [ __ ] up bro no no that
they call me that it's not to me where
money man it's not up to you what they
call you even though you have this well
they're like y'all this guy's getting so
many bags that we're calling money man I
never saw so many bags bags money
alright so you stay in your bag yeah oh
yeah you know what that means mm-hmm
they're stealing my bag
no you staying your bag you know that
means your what's that mean stay in your
face you know stay and keep your credit
up good quitting keep it up
what does it mean just getting your
money and getting to the money like all
he really in his bag right now he's
right cuz he's talking about accounting
there's heart into debits
I don't really do catch I do mostly
credit okay but you said you're more
liquid right liquid is cash I'm more
illiquid yeah
Oh ill liquid okay okay okay did the
typing [ __ ] yeah he does that a lot
anyway so since you guys are on
tick-tock have you came across the
serial challenge there's a non tick-tock
I love Brickman's [ __ ] a serial
challenge what's the serial challenge so
this serial challenge is where there's
one person laying down face up with
their mouths wide open and you stick a
dick and get a second person brings milk
pours it in their mouth put cereal pours
it in their mouth and uses their mouth
as a bowl
that sounds dangerous he's not on
Instagram that suit so this is a good
Domon is something that dominatrix would
do to a millionaire yeah that sounds
like Willy ate him
so here is a video clip of this trend
that's happening right now I'm gonna
mute it because we don't really need
music I wonder what the appeal of it is
it's just another charge no that's like
fruity pebbles pebbles why don't you do
that why did he do the milk first yeah
this is like waterboarding was my fave
oh yeah I did I did say the other way
around huh cuz I'm like I don't put milk
first and then cereal yeah
I love icing Oh
oh yeah so I get to look for it too
that's that's important I love it I love
it
no offense you don't look like you
ticked up that's fine you don't have the
[ __ ] boy thing going on I don't and I
appreciate you noticing that but no it's
a compliment so huge caught me oh hey
what's up bro you're not a [ __ ] boy she
was like damn bro H got birds right he
was right yeah I had to accept that what
he was right I know how you came up high
it sounded but it was best to sit with
it yeah for real it's not something
understand what you're what you're where
you're at with it I'm just trying to hop
on it before it blows up and they're now
trying to play catch-up save the
responsible yeah I need the post I have
a post in like three weeks so I'm trying
to run away from that [ __ ] I don't want
to don't get me wrong no I get it I
would much rather do stuff like this and
only have one medium outside of like
YouTube and Facebook just for videos
that I have to post all right but like
until I get to that point I have to
still stay relevant because you want to
be able to connect with the younger
generation you want their money from
tickets you want that support of shows
you want that support for your videos
and if they're moving toward this plan
there's medium like least let me grab my
name so if I decide to do it later
somebody doesn't have my name's how to
sell me sell it to me so at least let me
grab that the barrier yeah that's true
you know every time there's a new
platform that pops up I'm always like
I'm gonna survey where is it gonna be
like a vine and
I don't know well vine you know I went
to [ __ ] vine tower or whatever that
was where all the Viners lived Oh in
Hollywood yeah it was pretty interesting
but the but the you're making [ __ ]
money dude like they were killing it Oh
like from brand deals because they
couldn't monetize their actual yeah dude
get like $200,000 or six seconds you
have no idea - they I went in his kids
you know and he had a fridge full of
just a [ __ ] brand of water that
fridge was just for the water very few
of them whatever they were able to
translate bachelors and they starve and
all of them hope they Bank their money I
really do yeah we all just gonna hope
you know but they usually don't you know
find that they don't I know a couple
people like on YouTube like one of my
girlfriends he bought his mom a g-wagen
about him were like the next month and
you know a lot of these cats are getting
money out here I just hope that they're
investing it to me - that's the biggest
stock snaring yeah like anything what
we're talking about
wanted to look older like doctor doctor
one until ago and he's licking some
young my my stockbroker broker this
young guy around my age but he like grew
the beard out just to look older and
then when he took pictures for his card
he had them make his beard look grace
like he look older Wow
yeah cuz I people trust you when you
look like you have to why dude branding
is everything you know what that just
needs to [ __ ] chill in front of his
millions of dollars that he just printed
out and then you just stand there and be
like trust me now [ __ ]
what print it out like a [ __ ] gnome
limit or Cash Money record you're
Mayweather with a bag of cash but when
it's Mayweather doing me you're like
that's real damn that's real yeah he has
the mayweather face along with it yeah
what cuz he had the experience yeah no
doubt he's in the Gulfstream jet - doing
it so you're like holy [ __ ] putting it
all in the [ __ ] tray table that's
crazy Sid and you know and you hear that
you're hearing over the thing they like
we're coming in for a landing and he
keeps his tray table out with cash like
damn he's rich and doesn't put a sea bed
off he's actually he's actually walking
around after descending yeah
he does not he does not move his seat
back he doesn't when they're doing that
[ __ ] airplane thing where they have
zero gravity and they don't you just
give doesn't give up no I'm the
stewardess is like is like hey excuse me
I was like your dick sucked again one
time I saw I liked the plane descended
too fast and it things feel silly and I
actually saw me wear that put the mask
on someone else before we put it on
herself I like this guy's whoa
maybe not supposed to do it you're
supposed to get yourself first this
buckaroo he's counterculture do you also
take out his life vests and inflated
inside he does it just for fun I've seen
a couple Tatsu a couple times yeah I
used to carries bags for that money but
hey you have it that's all very fine
have you seen a box it's very boring
hello see what have you seen a litter
box is very very technical very boring
it's like that mr. Fitz's boxer in the
world what's happening with these people
are like I'll be choking are they dying
well there's a lot of people saying like
someone's gonna die vroom there's always
someone that dies from a challenge they
know it's not funny a lady died from
drinking too much water for a radio
contest dude did someone die from chubby
bunny and then it says RI PE Oh
everybody and they still monetize that
video does somebody decide that from the
cinnamon challenge oh I think I feel
like someone shot I don't know coughing
are brain people got respiratory
problems though cuz the cinnamon went in
their lungs and all challenge
come on before eating Tide Pods oh darn
a laundry yeah that was girl who comes
up with that first of all I feel like
that's 100% of troll like a fellow
Steven out there is like let's make
people he tripod but then also who the
[ __ ] is actually going through with
that's what's scary yeah well I don't do
that one because it's so scary but one
person that I think is very good at this
stuff
she did the cinnamon challenge on
purpose
his clothes out yeah yeah very smart she
translated all that and eventually big
[ __ ] to an interview with Obama like
she's like [ __ ] viral video was her
cinnamon challenge hopping is weren't
she already had a bunch of that well
maybe but it this one went [ __ ] nuts
right and like so because of that she
got to translate into a bunch of [ __ ]
and she's you know she's she was
next-level touch it I thought
participating in those challenges like
the YouTube challenges like you know
when we all did the the mannequin
challenge like things like that like
that that was kind of fun it was like
the blindfolded challenge whatever but
things like this I'm like no thing my
favorite is still to date planking thank
you that was pretty good now she laughs
when I see it I laugh people got really
creative and I liked it yeah it's an
easy laugh for me you know the one that
was like why would anyone do that is the
one with the [ __ ] the condoms
snorting the condom one and they were
like did you guys ever do that one word
everyone somebody has a horse's head
hornacek no one's dancing or no no no
the harlem shake or the harlem break you
guys ever do that it's like like a bunch
of people show up right yeah we did that
one that was fun are you gonna do cereal
for your - no no probably not my
dissipated challenges no I really don't
I already do the facts too much like no
I just I just make my own stuff cuz I
feel like I mean don't get me wrong it's
a great way to like get your stuff
saying because if is if it's hidden
diagonal rhythm throws it up more
I've like what you gonna do after that
just keep posting man I think I just did
a very nicely timed kobe post that was
excellent for me I thought it wasn't
about Kobe well that's so everyone said
that's what I heard about it so now
you're labeling it as I didn't even use
the hashtag yeah sometimes that stuff
works for you sometimes it doesn't data
work for you oh yeah with the most
hesitation ever me for me no no it
actually went exactly as planned
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]